all right now this is just simultaneous
equations that's it but it's just we put
it in log clothes and it looks Potter
okay now when you look at some of these
equations like say if I gave you simple
ones let's say this X minus y was 3 and
2x plus 3y just one ok what would be a
strategy to solve something like this
what would you do
I suppose if I said fine X just forget
about why I think what you do I said
fine it
years of trading has led to this point
okay if I want X I need to eliminate Y
right so I'm going to shift and change
these equations in whatever way I need
to so that when I combine them together
you have to combine that's why it's so
intense cravings when I combine them the
Y's will vanish and I'll be left with
the exits okay so it's exactly the same
deal here you've got log base a of all
this garbage that we need to get rid of
specifically the Y's so I'm left with a
log base a of X okay so what am I going
to do I only have to really muck around
with one of the equations in order to
make it fit the other just like here
what would you do I guess you maybe
multiply this by three then you just add
it and it would work right well here if
I've got equation one and equation two
it's probably easier I mean you could
take either anyway it's probably easier
to take one and shift this square root
of Y so that it'll be more like a Y
square okay and then we can take another
one so if I take equation one what must
I do to equation one to change this
square root Y so it's gonna be a Y
squared
maybe I should rewrite it this is a log
base a of x times and that's why the
powerful for it and that's equal one
okay now I I want this half to turn into
a - yes I've turned into two so what am
I going to have to do in here I'm gonna
need to have a four up there right cuz
that's a power issue okay cuz after fix
the power by one I've got a multiply
before to get up to two all right but I
can't just if I'm raising to a power for
this bitten here okay this X Y power
half I'm just in case you're curious and
will help you run it'll help you
describe these wenches a little bit up
this guy here is called the argument has
nothing to do with like I said this no
you said that that kind of thing it's
about what you even put into something
to make it work with it anyway I'm
raising the argument of power for not
the whole thing okay so putting this for
here doesn't put a four there right just
be careful
so in fact what am I do is going step
back you know your log laws right so if
I want power here aware that I can do
that an equivalent way is actually by
multiplying the whole thing by four okay
because I can move that coefficient up
into the power alright and that's
something I can do to the one as well
okay so for multiple left-hand side I'll
multiply the right-hand side as well so
now when I bring it up and go back to
the previous line I have X Y the huh-huh
so powerful it was full now I can
actually expand out my powers okay so
I'll get log base a of X to the 4 y
squared is that okay and that's equal to
four
okay so now that's ready I've done my
shifting in my changing too so now I can
put the equations together so since I
got this equation from Equation one I'm
going to call it one age just to make
sure I didn't put it back into the same
thing okay so now I've got one a and I'm
ready to combine it into but what way
should I can buy them this this is logs
right and I want this Y squared to
cancel with this y squared okay so the
first thing that comes to mind would be
division right because if I divide this
Y squared by this Y square it'll cancel
and I'll get my X's right but in laws
you might have noticed this is your
premier law Clause right Division is
equivalent to subtraction okay it's the
reverse of index laws okay so I'm gonna
take one a equation one a and I'm gonna
subtract two okay now you could do it
the other way around you just get a
double negative
okay so on the left hand side I'm gonna
have log base a all this guy - this one
here same thing for with an x squared
okay and that leaves me with three on
the right hand side 4-1 now from here
you could probably almost go straight to
the answer
almost I'll just put another one just to
make it a little more obvious here
I said subtraction is equivalent to
division right so this is equal to the
log base a of and this is why I bother
to introduce the word right subtraction
of these log terms means division of the
arguments okay so I'm gonna have this is
the first argued so it's the numerator
and this is the second idea so it's the
denominator okay and that's equal to
three so now my Y Squared's cancel just
like I wanted I'll have log base a of x
squared which is equal to three and now
I can just reverse the the trick I had
before which is that now I've got a
index power on the arguments of bring it
up front is the coefficient right so
this two I can just back out the front
and that's what gives me the actual term
that I'm after and if we change the
question to be Capulet log base a of Y
it'll be much the same thing except in
this step here as I sort of wiggle
around with one of the original
equations I would be doing it so that I
eliminate X instead of Y that's all
that's the only difference
okay so if you're like if you've a shady
with these no I'm not sure use that as a
practice question have a go at doing log
base a of Y from scratch to take an
equation one of them and manipulate it
such that it makes it easier to
eliminate the X terms any questions